[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chers amis aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
parler de la place de l'intelligence
artificielle dans la voie de l'inconnu
vous avez probablement entendu parler
d'IAS ou de nombreuses angles mais je
souhaiterais vous présenter une
perspective différente celle de
l'inconnu de ceux et celles qui n'ont
pas la chance de pouvoir s'exprimer
en effet lia peut-être utilisé pour
donner de la voix à ceux et celles qui
en sont privées qu'il s'agisse
de personnes handicapées de personnes
âgées ou encore de personnes vivant dans
des régions reculées
grâce à l'IA
nous pouvons
développer des outils de communication
alternative qui permettent à ces
personnes de s'exprimer et surtout de se
faire entendre
mais lia peut également être utilisé
pour donner de la voix à ceux et celles
qui sont opprimés ou marginalisés
imaginez un monde où les minorités
ethniques où les groupes LGBTQ plus pour
être utilisé l'IA pour exprimer leurs
points de vue sans être réduit ou
réduite au silence par la discrimination
ou encore la violence
enfin il y a peut-être utilisé pour
donner de la voix aux idées qui sont
ignorées voire mépriser par les
décideurs politiques et économiques
imaginez un monde où les citoyens et
citoyennes
pourraient être utilisés l'IA pour
exprimer leur préoccupations et
influencer les décisions qui les
concernent plutôt que d'être réduit ou
réduite au silence par la discrimination
ou encore la violence
bien sûr
il y a présente également des risques
et des défis et il est important de les
affronter de manière responsable mais je
suis convaincu que l'intelligence
artificielle peut être un outil puissant
pour donner de la voix à l'inconnu et
pour construire un monde plus juste et
plus inclusif merci de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
certains l'auront probablement remarqué
ce que vous venez d'entendre n'est
aucunement le fruit de mon imagination
ni même de mon travail pour obtenir ce
discours j'ai simplement émis une
requête à ce que l'on peut appeler donc
une intelligence artificielle qui est
maintenant bien connu de tous
puisque au coeur des discussions de
beaucoup d'entre nous il s'agit de chat
GPT comme vous avez pu l'entendre le
texte est construit correctement il ne
comporte aucune faute de syntaxe
même si l'on peine à percevoir la
direction sémantique que va prendre la
machine elle ne commet aucune erreur de
logique évidente
cette étape d'exactitude quasi parfaite
avait depuis longtemps été atteinte par
les différentes
nombre d'entre nous utilisent au
quotidien des assistants vocaux et leur
parle presque comme un humain les Alexa
Siri et autres font désormais partie de
notre vie et nous ne sommes plus
vraiment étonnés de discuter en langage
libre avec des machines
cependant la pertinence et la précision
de chat GPT ont fait grand bruit lors de
son entrée je dirais fracassante sur
internet il y a quelques mois cette
pertinence elle est intéressante parce
qu'elle est le fruit de l'absorption
d'une quantité gargantueuse que de
donner
issues de millions de pages internes une
quantité que jamais un être humain ne
pourrait consulter au cours de sa vie
personne ne peut en connaître plus que
l'intégralité des connaissances humaines
rassemblées
j'ai toujours été passionné par la
rédaction la littérature la philosophie
la rhétorique aussi comment la manière
de dire être interdépendante de la
manière de penser lorsque j'ai pour la
première fois eu vent de chat GPT il va
sans dire que ma curiosité à
instantanément été piquée j'ai voulu y
consacrer du temps à longueur d'échanges
avec la machine j'ai cherché à savoir si
les réponses que formules l'IA se
rapproche ou non sur le fond comme sur
la forme
des échanges humains que j'aime tant
qu'il s'agisse de traiter philosophique
mais surtout de discours politique ou
même de discussions entre amis qui dure
jusque tard dans la nuit
alors
que doit-on en penser
certains sont fans de la technologie et
il dit voit le remplacement d'énormément
de fonctions jusque là remplie par des
humains notamment pour la rédaction qui
vous l'avez vu et assez bluffante
effectivement les capacités sont
impressionnantes et elles ne doivent pas
être négligées
d'autres cependant critique et surtout
craignent un risque d'homogénéisation
des contenus et de risque
de chute de la motivation à produire du
contenu rédigé si la technologie
fonctionne correctement beaucoup ne
verront plus l'intérêt de d'écrire des
rapports ou des discours
et la majorité des textes disponibles se
verront donc tronquer d'une part de
personnalité que pourrait apporter le
rédacteur
peut-être
pourrait-on dire d'une part d'humanité
pour ma part je considère désormais
cette GPT comme un outil pratique
réellement utile
qu'il faut apprendre à maîtriser et qui
surtout appel est encourage la création
de toujours plus d'outils de ce type
mais sa force principale c'est qu'il se
veut adaptatif c'est à dire qu'il est
amené à évoluer en fonction des requêtes
que vous lui faites
il différer ainsi grandement des traités
philosophique écrit il y a plusieurs
siècles
et c'est en ça qu'il m'intéresse plus
qu'il ne m'impressionne lorsque je
demande à chat GPT de me produire un
contenu j'en attend qu'il fasse parler
une partie de moi que je ne connais pas
encore posé une question à
l'intelligence artificielle c'est poser
une question un esprit qui nous est
inconnu on ne cherche pas à le
comprendre
et qui pourtant prend en compte toute la
pensée que l'on ne conscientise pas
encore
cette GPT
ce serait comme un professeur qui
possède une culture presque infinie
et qui serait la restituer différemment
en fonction de son interlocuteur
alors attention il serait dangereux de
le voir comme une autorité morale ou
scientifique il se trompe il se trompe
souvent
c'est en fait l'ensemble de ce qui est
connu par l'être humain et qui donc nous
est à chacun presque entièrement inconnu
il nous faut alors l'apprivoiser
l'utiliser si l'on souhaite le faire
garder en tête ses forces culturelles
bien sûr mais surtout c'est faiblesses
intellectuelles jamais il n'y a ne
deviendra héro ou héroïne de révolution
jamais un grand discours prononcé avec
le coeur n'aurait été écrit par unir
elle restera à l'abri de la célébrité
telle qu'on la connaît quand bien même
tout le monde se mettrait à l'utiliser
lorsque j'avais compris cela
il va sans dire que
ma curiosité
a été piquée mais surtout
j'ai été grandement rassuré la part de
moi amatrice de rhétorique surtout de
poésie un peu
et être heureuse de ça alors
si aujourd'hui j'ai voulu vous parler de
cet outil c'est avant tout pour que vous
reteniez une chose
pour atteindre la vérité il faut une
fois dans la vie se défaire de toutes
les opinions qu'on a reçues et
reconstruire de nouveau tout le système
de ses connaissances
les plus attentifs ont reconnu ce qui a
écrit des cartes il y a 400 ans
oui aucune opinion brute n'est utile
dans la recherche de la vérité
j'oserais ajouter dans la recherche de
la beauté
avoir une pensée complètement
déconstruite pour se repencher sur un
nouveau système de connaissances que
l'on sait vrai c'est aujourd'hui ce que
nous propose lire comme ce que nous
proposait des cartes donc dans le
Discours de la méthode effectivement
nous pouvons utiliser l'IA
comme un prétexte
pour reconstruire ce que l'on connaît
et ainsi trouver des solutions aux
problèmes que rencontre notre société
sexisme réchauffement climatique
injustice sociale racisme tous sont dus
à l'archaïsme de la pensée établie
je ne dis bien sûr pas que lia apportera
des solutions à tout cela c'est évident
le texte que je vous ai présenté au
début
n'était pas si pertinent au final
certains parmi vous ont probablement été
déçus du vide intellectuel qu'il
proposait malgré cette déception je dois
vous avouer que j'ai personnellement
ressenti une certaine joie lorsque j'ai
compris que j'ai pété ne saurait me
remplacer aujourd'hui
mais vous pouvez vous convaincre que
l'apport de ce nouveau prix
doit nous pousser à remettre en question
intégralement nos jugements nos opinions
je suis certain que nous avons à y
gagner
saisissons donc cette opportunité de
construire un monde meilleur
car des révolutions de pensées comme
celles que nous pouvons voir venir
ne surviennent que trop rarement
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]